alors que de leur manque de choses hein
vous verrez ferrée pour ceux qui
regardent l'émission mais visuellement
vous faites pas votre travail
nadia 70% dans chaque émission fini a
alors fini c'est alors il en termine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme ça pour moi je termine et deuxième
chose
regardez aussi les yeux la regarder tous
les autres pays qui font un agréable
talent il ya aussi beaucoup d'étrangers
dedans parce que le but n'est pas de
mettre que des français c'est pas une
émission nationale
le but c'est aussi ça s'appelle comment
la france a sélectionné alors en ukraine
en ukraine y avait des français des
anglais des skis s'est retournée
priorité au direct
oui c'est vous qui avez fait mouche
c'est vous qui avez insultés madame
nakamura
mais si j'étais vous je me tairai vous
est discrédité pour donner votre opinion
et quand vous parlez de la france un à
creil talent c'est un scandale caroline
a raison y'a que des ukrainiens des
russes et alors quoi
ils disent qu'ils vont chercher des gens
dans les territoires français c'est faux
franchement matthieu delormeau contentez
vous de ce que vous connaissez vous
taire merci
[Rires]
on va voir un intermédiaire
il a devancé l'américain dan spirit
malouda mais l'incroyable billère
regarder daha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois tout simplement disposition du
sport
[Musique]
mais non
[Applaudissements]
et ça fait plaisir mais ça fait plaisir
d'avoir revu l'ex de beinheim 28
isabelle essayer d'avoir un tout petit
peu de juges et autres
revenez les pieds sur terre il dit vous
que vous ratissez la crème talent sans
ce passage en fait voilà ça c'est ce que
j'avais fait dire bonjour les s'exprime
normal alors allez c'est bon ça va le
melon invasive ça suffit je suis pas et
il ya une tournée régionale pour
effectuer talents en france vous
regardez le grand cabaret 80% des
articles
[Applaudissements]
bien dit me taire et faire les comptes
retour sur fond gris roquetoire
et là vous verrez tous les horizons plus
te voir tourner moi vous du drame
on doit l'avouer
[Applaudissements]
c'est le seul sur ce plateau n'a pas
compris qu'on ne voulait plus lui ça
vous êtes comme sajid pour ses terres
noires ton amant non c'est terminé
il est meilleur que toi j'ai une porte
de derrière bout de chaîne alors oui
alors finissez avec oui je vous dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]